اللهم ارحم شهدائنا وشهدائنا جميعا
المسلمين
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم استشهدوا الفتى
الفلسطيني عامر ابو زيتون برصاصه قوات
الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها مخيم بلاطه شرقيه
نابلس وحركه حماس تشيد بمجموعه عرين
الاسود في تصدي مقاومها للاقتحان في حين
يعقدوا مجلس الامن جلسه بشان انتهاك
الاحتلال في القدس واقتحامته للاقصى
واعتداءاته على المقابر المسيحيه في
المدينه
نقابه المحامين التونسيين تشدد على انها
لن تقف مكتوبه الايدي ولن تقبل بما سمته
قضاء تابعا لاي جهه سياسيه خلال تنظيمها
وقفه احتجاجيه رفضا لقانون الماليه الجديد
والرئيس قيس سعيد يتهم جهات لم يسميها
بتلقي تمويل من الخارج لتعطيني انتخابات
مجلس النواب وعرقله مرافقه عموميه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يؤكد
لنظيره الروسيه فلاديمير بوتين ان الدعوات
للسلام والتفاوض يجب دعمها بوقف اطلاق نار
من جانب واحد وبوتين يبدي استعداد بلاده
لما سماه حوارا جادا شريطه تنفيذ اكياس
شروط موسكو والاخف الاعتبار الواقع الجديد
على الارض شركه تجاره الالكترونيه
الامريكيه العملاقه امازون تستعد لتسريح
اكثر من 18 الف موظفا خاصه في قطاعات
التوظيف وعمليات البيع بالتجزئه بسبب ما
وصفتها بحاله عدم اليقين الاقتصادي
الراهنه وعمليات التوظيف التي اجرتها
بسرعه في السنوات الاخيره